[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin schönen guten Abend
zusammen Katja Stresow ist wieder mit
mir im Studio für den Sport genau so
sieht's aus schönen guten Abend dann
verschaffen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
einen Überblick
das Oktoberfest ist eröffnet nach zwei
Jahren wird in München wieder gefeiert
ganz ohne corona-auflagen
Wut nach Tod einer jungen Iranerin sie
stirbt nach der Festnahme durch die
Sittenpolizei tausende protestieren
und bittere Niederlage bei der EM die
deutschen Basketballer unterliegen im
Halbfinale knapp Spanien und spielen
jetzt um Bronze
[Musik]
seit heute findet wieder das größte
Volksfest der Welt das Münchner
Oktoberfest statt allerdings stellen
viele die Art und Weise nach zwei Jahren
Corona Pause in Frage bzw ihnen ist
dabei mulmig zumute ganz anders war das
2019 da feierten noch 6,3 Millionen
Besucher unbeschwert auf der Wiesen im
Jahr darauf erließen die Münchner
Behörden dann eine
corona-zwangspause da wurde die
Theresienwiese dann zum Drive-In jetzt
da wurde dann getestet jetzt ist das
Fest zurück die Pandemie ist nicht
beendet und von corona-strategie will
niemand etwas wissen über die Eröffnung
und die Debatte Claudia Vogelmann
nach zwei Jahren Pause stürmen sie auf
die Theresienwiese es gilt einen Platz
im Zelt zu sichern und diejenigen die
einen Sitzplatz ergattert haben müssen
noch vier Stunden warten bis das erste
Bier fließt
Botschaft ist auf eine friedliche Wiese
der bayerische Ministerpräsident und
Münchens ob machen es vor Dichtern dicht
feiernde Besucher ohne Abstand und Maske
bierselig geht es zu in den großen
Festzelten für das größte erfolgsfest
der Welt gibt es keine einzige
corona-auflage die die Menschen vor
einer neuen möglichen viruswelle
schützen könnte Corona spielt schon eine
Rolle aber ich habe mich dazu
entschlossen dass wir die Menschen
zwischendurch mal wieder die Gelegenheit
geben muss ein bisschen abzuschalten
dazu dient das Oktoberfest und wie sie
hören und sehen die Menschen genießen
die sich Freiheit und das heißt ja nicht
dass wir das andere verdrängt oder Weg
leugnet ein Fest das Millionen Menschen
anzieht der Virologe Martin Stürmer
rechnet damit dass sich viele Besucher
mit dem Virus infizieren werden
wir haben das giftige Gefahr dass ich
die Varianten eben auch wieder in die
Welt verbreiten in einem größeren Maße
als uns lieb ist wir haben die Gefahr
dass ich wenn ein Mensch sich mit zwei
Viren ist Varianten infiziert das wäre
rekombinationseffekte also komplett neue
zusammengesetzte Viren bekommen der
Bierpreis bis zu 13 Euro 80 pro Maß wird
geschluckt das halbe Händel für 14,50 €
wird geordert die Gefahr sich
anzustecken wird oft ignoriert maximal
geimpftinfektion durchgemacht
[Musik]
schlimmer kann es nicht werden ich denke
dass wir das jetzt mit den Impfungen
ganz gut im Griff haben deswegen ist für
mich Corona jetzt eigentlich vorbei für
die einen ist der Wunsch nach
unbeschwerten Zeiten groß andere Sorgen
sich wegen einer großen
Ansteckungsgefahr die das Oktoberfest
mit sich bringen könnte
Stefan leifert ist für uns beim Münchner
Oktoberfest Stefan die Stadt sagt also
uneingeschränkt ja zum Fest wieso hat
denn auch die Opposition keine Einwände
formuliert
Opposition das hätte auf Ebene der Stadt
München ja bedeutet die CSU und die CSU
hier in München die ist ganz auf dem
Kurs des CSU-Chef und
Ministerpräsidenten Markus Söder der ja
eine 180 Grad Wende vollzogen hat und
komplett gewechselt ist vom Team
Vorsicht ins teamlebensfreude der
Oberbürgermeister Münchens hatte zwar
seine Bauchschmerzen aber es gibt in
Bayern keine nennenswerte Kraft die
gegen diese Form des Oktoberfest gewesen
wäre das dafür gibt es zwei Gründe das
eine ist ein rechtlicher Grund es gab
keine rechtliche Grundlage dafür dieses
Oktoberfest mit Auflagen stattfinden zu
lassen wie zum Beispiel einer
testpflicht und der zweite Grund ist ein
wirtschaftlicher das Oktoberfest ist ein
immenser wirtschaftlicher Faktor und man
wollte vor allem im Hinblick auf die
Schausteller die nach zwei Jahren Corona
Zwangspause wirklich gebeutelt sind
nicht noch mal dieses Oktoberfest
Absagen alle hier wissen dieses
Oktoberfest wird die Infektionszahlen
nach oben treiben teilweise
verdreifachen vervierfachen
möglicherweise das hat die bisherige
Volksfestsaison in Bayern gezeigt sie
hat aber auch gezeigt dass die
krankenhausbelastungs mal nicht im
gleichen Maße mitsteigen und die
Hoffnung dass das in München jetzt auch
so sein möge das ist die Hoffnung in der
das Oktoberfest heute hier beginnt dann
danke für die Einordnung nach München
Stefan leifert war das jetzt in die
Ukraine nach der Rückeroberung der
ostukrainischen Stadt istium und dem
Pfund Hunderter Leichen fordert
Präsident selensky eine Reaktion der
Weltgemeinschaft die Welt dürfe nicht
zusehen wie Russland töte und foltere
die Gegenoffensive der ukraineischen
Armee in der Region hält unvermendet
weiter an Michael ferlert violand
berichtet
aus der Luft ist das Waldstück zu
erkennen auf das die ganze Welt derzeit
mit Entsetzen blickt hier liegen die
mehr als 400 Gräber nahe der Stadt
Island die Opfer wohl überwiegend
Zivilisten noch werden sie untersucht
russische Vertreter machen die
ukrainische Armee verantwortlich für die
Ukraine ist klar es waren russische
Soldaten Präsident selensky fordert
härtere Sanktionen gegen Russland
es gibt bereits klare Beweise für Folter
erniedrigende Behandlung von Menschen
und Beweise das russische Soldaten deren
Position nicht weit von dieser Stelle
waren auf die beerdigten einfach aus
Spaß geschossen haben
Vorwürfe die bald ein Team der UN vor
Ort prüfen will
ist einer der größten Städte die bei der
Gegenoffensive zurückerobert wurde die
Frontlinie hat sich immer weiter
Richtung Osten verschoben bis zum Fluss
aus Kiel heute spricht die britische
Regierung von einer neuen russischen
Verteidigungslinie zwischen dem Fluss
und der Stadt swatoveville an der der
ukrainische Vorstoß aufgehalten werden
soll vor allem aber wolle Russland eine
hauptversorgungsroute zur russischen
Grenzregion Belgorod nicht verlieren
einfach weil dann praktisch der
Nachschub vor den zu diesem Teilen nicht
mehr läuft zu anderen russischen teilen
die weiter im Süden sind von hier aus
nicht mehr läuft und damit wären
erhebliche russische Kräfte von jeder
Form des Nachschubs in der Logistik
abgeschnitten Videos die heute online
zirkulierten deuteten auf weitere
Geländegewinne der Ukraine im Osten hin
verifiziert und bestätigt werden kann
das bislang nicht
der Tod einer 22-jährigen bewegt die
iranische Öffentlichkeit die
Sittenpolizei hatte sie während eines
familienbesuches festgenommen weil sie
offenbar ihr Kopftuch den hijob nicht
korrekt trug seit der islamischen
Revolution 1979 gelten im Iran strenge
Bekleidungsvorschriften seit Jahren
kämpfen aber viele Frauen vor allem im
Großstädten dafür den Hijab abzulegen
oder legera zu tragen was streng
geahndet wird im Fall der toten jungen
Frau gibt es jetzt Foltervorwürfe die
Wut im Land ist groß wie Jörg Brase
berichtet
tausende waren gekommen um Marsa Amini
die letzte Ehre zu erweisen wir
Begräbnis wurde zum politischen Protest
Tod dem Diktator riefen viele und meinen
Irans Religionsführer toller Grammel
macht das Familie steht noch immer unter
Schock
ich habe der Polizei im Krankenhaus ihre
Kleider gezeigt ruft ihre Tante am Grab
ich habe gefragt was stimmt damit nicht
unsere Arme Tochter ist unschuldig
weil sie angeblich gegen die streng
islamischen Kleidervorschriften
verstoßen haben soll war Maße am
Dienstag verhaftet worden viel kurz
darauf in Polizei Gewahrsam ins Koma
dass sie geschlagen worden sei streiten
die Behörden ab sie veröffentlichten ein
Video es soll beweisen das Masse Amini
einen Infarkt erlitt und plötzlich
zusammenbrach doch viele Iranerinnen und
Iraner glauben dass sie eines
gewaltsamen Todes starb
offiziell heißt es sie hatte einen
Gehirnschlag erlitten das akzeptieren
wir nicht das muss korrigiert werden
ich lehne dieses Vorgehen ab und ich
lehne auch die Funktion der moralpolizei
ab
Regierungschef reissi ordnete eine
sofortige Untersuchung an doch für viele
die Masse Amini heute zu Grabe trugen
stehen die Schuldigen fest Irans
religiöse Hardliner und ihre brutalen
Moralwächter es herrschen Trauer und Wut
während alle auf das offizielle
Untersuchungsergebnis warten
zurück nach Deutschland wegen Inflation
und
energiepreisschock verschlechtert sich
auch die wirtschaftliche Situation
vieler Unternehmen deswegen warten
Wirtschaftsverbände zuletzt immer wieder
vor einer stark steigenden Zahl an
Insolvenzen und was ist da dran aktuelle
Zahlen belegen diesen Trend jedenfalls
bislang nicht Isabel de la Vega hat
nachgefragt
Kühlräume und Öfen die rund um die Uhr
arbeiten der Energiebedarf der
Großbäckerei dries ist riesig und vor
allem teuer in einem Jahr sind die
Kosten von 440.000 Euro auf über 900.000
angestiegen Firmenchef dries aber hat
ein Finanzpolster aus guten Zeiten
im Moment kommen wir damit noch gut
zurecht weil wir solide Rücklagen haben
aber wenn wir die nächsten Monate und ja
antizipieren dann wird das so nicht
tragbar vor einer riesigen
Insolvenzwelle warnen die
Wirtschaftsverbände und fordern
Subventionen doch die Zahl der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen befindet sich
auf einem historischen Tiefstand der
Grund bei der corona-krise gab es
Milliardenhilfen viele Unternehmen die
ohne diese Subventionen pleite gegangen
wären konnten sich am Markt halten
dieser Effekt verpufft nun langsam
selbst wenn wir jetzt eine deutliche
Zunahme bei den Insolvenzen haben ist
das noch keine fatale Insolvenzwelle die
die deutsche Volkswirtschaft nachhaltig
schaden könnte sondern es ist
tatsächlich eher eine Normalisierung
weil wir eben einen großen Rückstau
haben der erstmal sukzessive abgebaut
werden müsste
energieintensive Unternehmen könnten im
kommenden Jahr Probleme bekommen doch
Subventionen nach dem Gießkannenprinzip
sein das falsche so Experten Unternehmen
die in guten Zeiten Gewinde gemacht
haben sollten nicht in schlechten Zeiten
nach dem Steuerzahler rufen ich halte es
für denkbar dass man Unternehmen
zweckgebundene Kredite gibt um die
Produktion Energie sparen da umzustellen
Martin dries sieht dem Strukturwandel
ins Auge er wird die Backzeiten
komprimieren um Energie zu sparen und an
allen Standorten Photovoltaikanlagen
installieren
in der serbischen Hauptstadt Belgrad
sind heute hunderte Anhänger der
Schwulen Lesben Bi und transbewegung auf
die Straße gegangen bei der EuroPride
eigentlich hatte das Innenministerium
die Parade verboten wegen angekündigter
Gegenproteste von rechten Gruppen beide
Seiten gingen trotzdem auf die Straße
begleitet von hunderten Einsatzkräften
Anfang November finden in den USA die
Zwischenwahlen statt und lange sah es in
Umfragen nach einem klaren Sieg für die
konservativen Republikaner aus aber
deren Kandidaten schwächeln gerade
weswegen die Republikaner mit noch
härteren Bandagen kämpfen um den in der
Einwanderungspolitik liberaleren
Demokraten einen Denkzettel zu verpassen
greifen die Republikaner zu
grenzwertigen Maßnahmen Benjamin Daniel
berichtet
Bilder gedreht vor wenigen Stunden im
Herzen Washingtons schon wieder wurden
dutzende Asylbewerber größtenteils aus
Venezuela vor die Residenz der
Vizepräsidenten gekarrt veranlasst vom
republikanischen Gouverneur aus Texas
diesmal sind es rund 50 Flüchtlinge
viele davon Kinder es ist sogar ein vier
Wochen altes Baby dabei sie wurden hier
vom navelope servatory einfach
rausgeschmissen
auch andere republikanische Gouverneure
lassen Migranten in demokratisch
geprägte Regionen bringen wie ronde
Santis aus Florida er ließ am Mittwoch
mehrere Dutzend auf die noble
Ferieninsel Martha's Vineyard vor der
Küste Massachusetts fliegen die
Republikaner kritisieren mit ihren für
viele menschenverachtenden Aktionen die
aus ihrer Sicht zu Lachse
Einwanderungspolitik der Regierung
wir wollen klar machen wir sind kein
zufluchtsstaat die Menschen sollen
dahingehend wo man ihnen helfen will und
wir helfen Ihnen gerne dabei den
Transport zu diesen tollen Orten zu
organisieren
und während des Santes für seinen
Sarkasmus Applaus erntet steigt die
Verzweiflung bei mehr und mehr Menschen
die die Republikaner als
wahlkampfinstrument benutzen
anstatt mit unseren Lösungen zu arbeiten
spielen die Republikaner Politik mit
Menschen und benutzen sie als Requisiten
was sie tun ist falsch ohne amerikanisch
und rücksichtslos
die Asylbewerber auf Martas vinjad
wurden von Helfern mittlerweile in einen
Militärstützpunkt auf Cape Court
gebracht der nächste Stopp auf ihrer
ungewissen Reise
jetzt zur Trauer um Königin Elisabeth
der zweiten hunderttausende wollen es
noch bis Montagmorgen vor der Beisetzung
schaffen und nehmen stundenlanges Warten
in Kauf um ihrer verstorbenen Majestät
die letzte Ehre zu erweisen aber für
viele hat sich das Warten heute
besonders gelohnt wir uns Alisa jung
jetzt zeigt
König Charles
und träumen lassen viele Stunden stehen
sie hier in London an um Queen Elizabeth
der zweiten die Ehre zu erweisen
das ist das Ende der Schlange letzte
Nacht und es kommen immer mehr so wie
die Schwestern Joanne und Paula extra
angereist aus lenkerschaft
wir mussten
danke sagen weil sie uns ihrem Volk mehr
als 70 Jahre lang gedient hat
warme Kleidung Brote damit wollen sie
die Stunden überstehen 14 oder mehr
heißt es kurz vor Mitternacht
wer es geschafft hat erlebt das ganz
still ein letztes Mal mit der Queen
nach dem Sonnenaufgang nach fast 14
Stunden erleben das auch Joanne und
Paula
es war großartig tolle Leute haben mit
uns gewartet
jeder hat nach dem anderen geschaut wir
haben alle gesagt ohne einander hätten
wir es nicht geschafft
darauf trinken Sie zum Schluss
wir sind jetzt beim Sport und bei Katjas
war spannend es war knapp aber am Ende
hat es leider nicht gereiht für ein
m-final-ticket em final Ticket für
basketball team leider nicht
Deutschlands Basketballer haben im
Halbfinale toll gespielt aber eben doch
mit 91 zu 96 gegen Spanien verloren auch
ein mit 30 Punkten herausragender Dennis
Schröder konnte die Niederlage nicht
verhindern der finaltraum ist geplatzt
gut gespielt aber Weltmeister Spanien
eben noch ein klein wenig besser und in
der entscheidenden Phase souveräner
es war meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen
mehr drin das Finale war war erreichbar
ein wieder spannendes Spiel mit einem
überragenden Kapitän Dennis Schröder der
nach der Partie bekannt gab dass er in
der neuen NBA-Saison zu den Los Angeles
Lakers zurückkehrt 30 Punkte für ihn
aber im vierten Viertel schafften es die
Spanier Schröder weitestgehend aus dem
Spiel zu nehmen
was dir passiert sondern wie du darauf
reagierst wir müssen jetzt einfach
weitermachen
denn morgen kommt noch das ganz wichtige
Spiel gegen Polen es geht um Bronze eine
Medaille war das erklärte Ziel
[Applaus]
gestern Abend auch Auftakt für die neue
fußball-bundesliga-saison der Frauen und
wie erhofft scheint die Fan Euphorie von
der EM im Sommer anzuhalten Tore gab es
zwar keine zwischen Eintracht Frankfurt
und Bayern München dafür aber eine
Rekordkulisse von
23.200 Zuschauern
riesen Andrang vor der Frankfurter Arena
drinnen beste Stimmung auch ohne Treffer
denn mitreißende Torszenen gab es
trotzdem vereitelt von großartigen
Torfrauen erst hält Frankfurt Stina
Johannes den Schuss von Lina magul und
dann glänzt ihre Münchner Kollegin Maria
Luisa groß gegen sheraldin Reuter
dies nur die besten Chancen eines
saisonauftaktspiels das trotz fehlender
Tore zu gefallen wusste
ja und von diesem kulissenerlebnis
erzählt heute Abend sicherlich auch
Eintracht Spielerin Laura Freigang sie
ist gemeinsam mit Felicitas Rauch vom
siegreichen VfL Wolfsburg zu Gast im
Aktuellen Sportstudio von 23 Uhr an
indem es natürlich auch um die Spiele
des 7 spieltags der Männer geht hier
schon mal die Ergebnisse Dortmund
gewinnt das Derby gegen Schalke 1:0 muss
aber eine Verletzung von Marco Reus
verkraften der unglücklich umknickte die
Bayern verlieren in Augsburg 0:1 der
schlechteste saisonstark für den FCB
seit zwölf Jahren Stuttgart und
Frankfurt spielen 1:3 und Leverkusen
Bremen eins zu eins im Abendspiel
empfängt Gladbach RB Leipzig und bereits
gestern trennen sich Mainz und die
Hertha Unentschieden 1 zu 1
in der Tabelle der BVB vorn Union Berlin
und oder Freiburg können morgen aber
wieder vorbei ziehen die Bayern nur auf
vier noch vor Hoffenheim Frankfurt und
Mainz die zweite Hälfte führt Bremen an
dahinter jetzt Augsburg Leipzig und die
Hertha ganz unten Stuttgart und heute
noch Wolfsburg Schlusslicht weiterhin
Bochum und noch die ist die erst
15-jährige sportgymnastin da ja
Fahrschule vom TSV Schmiden hat bei der
WM insofern nach Gold nun auch Silber im
Mehrkampf gewonnen da räumt eine ab und
da gratulieren wir Dankeschön und das
noch quasi gerade hatten wir eine
Hitzewelle und extreme Dürre und jetzt
ja jetzt liegt schon der erste Schnee
man traut seinen Augen kaum und zwar
hier auf dem Nebelhorn in den Allgäuer
Alpen 10 cm bei 2 Grad unter 0 da hilft
nur das Beste draus machen und die
Bierzeltgarnituren so ganz langsam
wieder reinholen
in den Niederungen nicht ganz so kalt
aber herbstlich und unbeständig mehr
wettergleich mit Christa Orden wir
liegen ihnen um 22 Uhr noch das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers ans Herz
das war es von uns schönen Samstagabend
und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend der Herbst ist in
Mitteleuropa angekommen mit um 10 15
Grad ist es bei uns im Moment ähnlich
kühl wie in Skandinavien und heute Nacht
gehen die Temperaturen ja noch mal etwas
zurück meist auf 11 bis 5 Grad in
höheren Lagen kann es auch noch kühler
sein und das gilt zum Beispiel für die
Alpen wo es heute Nacht oberhalb von
1400 Metern weiter schneit im Osten gibt
es showerartigen Regen und einen Bögen
Westwind zwischen dem Harz und dem
Erzgebirge und in der zweiten
Nachthälfte verdichtet sich auch der
Regen von Westen her wieder und breitet
sich dann morgen von Nordrhein-Westfalen
bis nach Ostbayern und Westsachsen aus
und in genau diesem Streifen kann es
teils den ganzen Tag regnen bis zu 20
Liter pro Quadratmeter sind möglich und
das ist für die Natur wirklich ein Segen
im Norden und im Osten gibt es vor allem
vormittags viele sonnige Abschnitte
später machen sich dann aber wieder
Schauer und einzelne Gewitter breit und
später ist auch Richtung Berchtesgadener
Land wieder mehr Regen möglich dazu gibt
es diesen frischen Wind der vor allem an
der Nordsee und in Kammlagen Sturmböen
dabei haben trocken bleibt es nur ganz
im Südwesten wo wir mit
sonnenunterstützung 17 Grad erreichen
ansonsten gibt es im Dauerregen 9
außerhalb 15 Grad in der neuen Woche da
wird es nur langsam milder am Montag ist
es auch im Norden und im Osten noch nass
dann gibt es von Südwesten
Hochdruckeinfluss tschüss